OKAY.
WHICH WAY DO YOU WANT TO KICK?
>> Jesse: FLORIDA GOVERNOR RON
DESANTIS JOINS US NOW FROM
NAPLES HIGH SCHOOL.
WHAT'S THE ENERGY IN THE CROWD
LIKE?
>> I THINK IT'S FANTASTIC,
JESSE.
I MEAN, WE HAD 10 FEET OF STORM
SURGE NOT TOO FAR FROM HERE JUST
NINE DAYS AGO.
AND MORE THAN THEY HAVE EVER HAD
IN THIS COUNTY.
SCHOOLS ARE BACK OPEN.
WE ARE HERE FOR HIGH SCHOOL
FOOTBALL.
AND PEOPLE, I THINK, HAVE REALLY
UNITED.
WE TOOK A BLOW ON THIS STORM.
BUT WE ARE GOING TO BOUNCE BACK
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
SOMETHING SIMILAR IN LEE COUNTY,
HOPEFULLY, IN THE NOT TOO
DISTANT FUTURE AS WELL AS SOME
OF THE SURROUNDING COUNTIES.
OF YOU KNOW, PEOPLE HAVE REALLY
PITCHED IN TOGETHER.
WE HAVE MADE TREMENDOUS PROGRESS
SO FAR.
BUT WE KNOW WE GOT A LOT OF WORK
TO DO.
I THINK EVERYONE IS IN REALLY
GOOD SPIRITS CONSIDERING THE
CIRCUMSTANCES.
>> Jesse: I LOVE HEARING THE
DRUMS, THE WHISTLE IN THE
BACKGROUND, THE CROWD BEHIND YOU
IN THE STANDS.
IT'S JUST A GREAT FEEL.
THAT MUST JUST FEEL SO GOOD
KNOWING WHAT YOU GUYS HAVE BEEN
THROUGH OVER THE LAST WEEK.
>> NO, FOR SURE.
BUT IT'S ALSO A TESTAMENT,
JESSE.
I MEAN, WOULD HE HAD 42,000
LINEMEN AND UTILITY WORKERS
STAGED IN FLORIDA BEFORE THE
STORM.
AND SO WE HAD MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
WITHOUT POWER.
WE'RE NOW 99 PLUS PERCENT OF ALL
FLORIDIANS HAVE POWER.
YOU KNOW, WE HAVE DONE 2500
SEARCH AND RESCUE MISSIONS.
BECAUSE WE HAD OUR DUCKS IN A
ROW, THAT HAS CLEARED THE WAY TO
BE ABLE TO RECOVER AND BOUNCE
BACK QUICKER THAN IF PEOPLE WERE
TOILING, YOU KNOW, WITHOUT THESE
ESSENTIAL SERVICES FOR THREE OR
FOUR WEEKS.
>> WHAT DID YOU THINK WHEN YOUR
STAFF HANDED YOU THIS A.P.
ARTICLE THAT KNOCKED YOU FOR NOT
HAVING A BRIDGE TO THIS PINE
ISLAND AND YOU ACTUALLY HAD THE
BRIDGE BACK UP AND RUNNING?
>> I LITERALLY HAD DONE A PRESS
CONFERENCE EARLIER THAT DAY AND
I NOTICED THE REPORTER FILED THE
REPORT FROM MINNEAPOLIS.
SO I DON'T KNOW TOO MANY PEOPLE
IN MINNEAPOLIS THAT GOT A BEAT
ON THE PULSE OF PINE ISLAND.
I CAN TELL YOU THIS, JESSE.
THEY WERE INITIALLY ADVISED AS
RESIDENTS TO GET OFF OF THE
ISLAND BECAUSE OF THE BRIDGE
THAT THEY WERE GOING TO BE
ISOLATED.
THEY REACHED OUT TO ME AND SAID
IS THERE ANYTHING THE STATE CAN
DO?
IT'S NOT OUR ROAD.
I SAID YEAH, WE ARE GOING IT DO
IT.
WE ARE GOING TO GET IT DONE.
WE DID IT AHEAD OF SCHEDULE AND
NOW WE ARE DOING THE SAME THING
ON.
>> Sandra: ANY BELL ISLAND TO SL
ISLAND.
STILL TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
EXACTLY WHEN BUT IT WILL BE IN
OCTOBER.
>> Jesse: THAT'S GREAT TO HEAR.
THOSE BRIDGES ARE SO CRITICAL
BUT SYMBOLICALLY CRITICAL AND
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT VISUALLY
FOR THE REST OF THE COUNTRY TO
UNDERSTAND.
WHEN JOE BIDEN WAS DOWN THERE
VISITING WITH YOU HOW WERE
THINGS WITH THE PRESIDENT?
>> WELL, I WILL TELL YOU WHAT, I
MEAN WHAT I TOLD HIM BECAUSE THE
MEDIA WAS MAKING A BIG DEAL THAT
HE WASN'T TALKING TO ME OR
WHATEVER.
I TOLD THEM I WAS LIKE LOOK, I
WANT TO WORK TOGETHER FOR THESE
PEOPLE.
BECAUSE THESE PEOPLE ARE FROM
ALL WALKS OF LIFE, REPUBLICANS,
DEMOCRATS, THEY EXPECT US TO BE
ABLE TO PUT OUR DIFFERENCES
ASIDE.
AND NOBODY HAS DONE MORE TO
STAND UP TO THE ADMINISTRATION
THAN ME IN FLORIDA OVER THE LAST
YEAR AND A HALF AS YOU KNOW.
BUT YOU GOT TO BE WILLING TO
WORK TOGETHER TO HELP FOLKS AND
SO I THINK THE RESPONSE FROM
LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL HAS BEEN
PRETTY SEEMLESS.
AND I THINK THAT'S A TESTAMENT
THAT, YOU KNOW WHAT?
WE AS A COUNTRY CAN ACTUALLY GET
THINGS DONE WHEN IT COUNTS.
>> Jesse: YEAH THAT WAS VERY
INSPIRATIONAL TO SEE.
NO ONE WAS MONKEYING AROUND AND
SCREWING THINGS UP.
NOW, I THINK EVERYBODY WOULD
AGREE THAT YOUR WIFE CASEY
REALLY IS THE SECRET WEAPON.
>> NOT ONLY THAT SHE, HER
FLORIDA DISASTER FUND.ORG, WHICH
SHE LAUNCHED LAST WEEK RAISED
OVER $40 MILLION.
GO TO WEBSITE YOU CAN
CONTRIBUTE.
THAT MONEY SHE NEGOTIATED NO
TRANSACTION FEES FROM VISA AND
MASTER CARD.
100% OF YOUR DONATION IS GOING
TO THESE ORGANIZATIONS.
WE GOT GREAT ORGANIZATIONS ON
THE GROUND THAT WILL USE THAT
FUNDING TO HELP THE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE BEEN DISPLACED FROM THIS
STORM.
>> IF OUR AUDIENCE RIGHT NOW
WANTS TO DONATE, WHERE SHOULD
THEY GO?
>> FLORIDA DISASTER FUND.ORG.
>> Jesse: ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU, GOVERNOR.
AND LET'S GO WATCH SOME
FOOTBALL.
GOOD I